Jewish stuff is like it's been like hot
recently right yeah yeah so it was
higher now was that a part of the reason
was it were you just happen to be
putting it out probably put it up you
have a new special album new special so
the Journey of this special is
interesting because I remember
yeah because I remember when you were do
you did this like you had started this
kind of years ago right yeah five and a
half years ago wow yeah
yeah it was it was uh
canceled a couple times but you know you
stopped me on first down and second down
I still got third I picked it up you
know third and fourteen I picked it up
Schumer Chase over here dude yeah
um well congratulations man thanks yeah
I watched about the first 20 minutes so
that's as far as I've gotten nice that's
more than I can watch most Comics even
to put it on is to like is a is like a
is a nice compliment like hey I loaded
up your thing yeah even if it's like I
loaded up I asked my mom called I forgot
to you know but like just to load it up
it's like cool well you know every comic
is like we know them all so we can't
watch them all yeah I um yeah and I love
the candles I love the setup kind of it
felt a little scary kind of a little bit
it felt a little like uh we'd gone down
into a hole in the desert and you were
kind of telling me some stories kind of
a little bit yeah it's got that campfire
Vibe versus like religiously kind of
feel yeah Indiana had a little bit of an
Indiana
did you feel like oh my God this is like
Kismet or whatever that I'm I'm putting
this thing out and now all there's all
this Jewish like uh anti or Semite stuff
and stuff happening no I thought it was
gonna be the end of it again I thought
it was gonna go fourth down yeah because
I saw a world
where they were the reaction to that was
going to be overly protective and they
go anything that's even remotely
anti-semitic where they wouldn't get a
joke they don't know what irony is you
know that anything remotely we're just
killing it so that we don't have to
worry about being called anti-semitic I
could see a world with that what
happened I would think the other thing
like people would be more there would
probably be more support for it you know
sure but I was like I wasn't looking for
that when I thought of putting it out so
I was like don't let it go away there is
a world you could see where that could
happen oh totally I mean it's hard to
have any type of um it's hard to have
any type of irony these days you know
um did you feel do you is your special
is it anti-semitical no no no no that's
not the word but um uh no it's not it's
very reverential and whatever but also
like yeah you make fun of yourself yeah
yeah none of these bits are like
are like timely they're all five
thousand year old Source material yeah
yeah you know so it's like there's no
there's no rush or not rush yeah you
know I took my time editing it I went to
Paris for like a couple weeks and people
like where's the edit notes my guy yeah
yeah sorry sorry you're the boss or
you're waiting on you I'm like [ __ ] yeah
but then um I was gonna do Rogan's I was
like that's a good time I'll just do it
the day after I do Rogan's so as soon as
it comes out I'll just have it and then
[ __ ] it blew up yeah old gold digger
[ __ ] took into the [ __ ] backlogs
and started promoting it that's awesome
it was interesting because if you'd have
done it in the beginning yeah it would
have been for Netflix no oh it wouldn't
have been yeah okay sorry I thought that
it was going to be for Netflix and then
now I ended up on YouTube and that would
have seemed like almost a better
Choice uh yeah it was always going to be
YouTube it was kind of like before
people were putting them on YouTube I
already had the thought of like no this
is the way it's like you can get it to
everybody you'll be like early on a
platform
um you still own it you still own it
sure they can't stick some [ __ ]
lady's name on the end of it as a
producer I never met once in my life or
ever talked to like who the [ __ ] is this
lady you guys just stuck on the end of
my [ __ ] yeah I think credits are
important you can't just stick some
[ __ ] lady's name on there uh they'll
yeah they'll just
sticky tacks and broth yeah I'm like
what
um
so yeah and it honestly was but I got to
like go back
to these jokes like with like a year and
a half off and go oh some of this is too
long these setups are too long and like
some of these like oh this is the same
joke twice I can't see if you know
forest for the trees kind of [ __ ] and
then I was able to like edit a lot
better it's a lot better because of all
that how much is it to shoot something
like that
this one cost me quite a bit
um they're expensive aren't they yeah
you can make them for for for very
little and you'll still get the jokes
across you know
it'll still be good but the way I wanted
to make it it costs it costs it costs a
lot a couple hundred g 230. wow yeah the
song cost 20. yeah isn't that crazy
you're like oh this song would be great
and like it's 20 grand and you're like
it was it was it was uh it was um
Satchmo what's his name uh Louis
Armstrong and it was it was eight grand
I was like okay wow that's not crazy
[ __ ] that's a lot of money but I'll pay
for it they go well also there's like a
chorus he uses on it so you got to pay
the chorus guy also I'm like how much is
he he's like he's 10. I'm like what and
they go yeah and they have favor Nation
so it's ten and ten oh and what we're
from eight to eight Nations they're both
from Africa aren't they yeah that's the
favorite Nation Oh I guess it is now huh
yeah it is now it's a favorite Nation I
got a promo shirt
let's get it out
um there we go Ari shaffir Jew dude no
more hiding that's right
out of the attic into your into your
homes I'm coming out of the attic dude
I'll say this about Anne Frank's Place I
went there yeah it's two bedroom two
bath massive overlooking a [ __ ] uh uh
River bro it's nice perfect location
yeah there's coffee shops everywhere
What a Wonder beautiful spot
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one